هل ستهدا الامور هم يلاحظون الان كما
نلاحظ ويشاهد مشاهد العربيه اعمده الدخان
التي تنتشر والاستماع الى صوت المدفعيه
الثقيله كما نسمع الان
حاجه جديده علينا طبعا حاجه جديده في
البلد
فالنادي المفروض يخلوا عندهم دينه ايمان
احنا نسواننا في الشوارع اطفالنا في
الشوارع زي ما شايف انت براك ذيل اطفال
قبل شوي انا في البيت جابوا مضروبات برصاص
خيطتهم في البيت يعني شغل ذاته ما مفهومه
وما معروفه جايه من وين ذاته الان في
اطلاق نار في اشتباكات داخل القاعده
بالطالب شنو كمواطنين منطقه مروي لو سمحت
والله نحن بنطالب بانه يعني الاحداث دي
تتلاشى ونحاول الدعم السريع دمج مع القوات
المسلحه والاشكالات تتحلى والاتفاق
الايطالي واصل في في برنامج الحاصل فيه
خالد كانت هذه بعض الاصوات قبل ان اختت